a taste for the classics is on the rise
inspiring droves of nostalgic gamers to
seek out old games and consoles but not
everyone wants to wade through flea
markets or enter into a bidding war in
eBay for 20 year old Super Nintendo this
is where a hardware company like hyper
Ken comes into play its line of retron
consoles has given fans of classic games
a new way to play Nintendo's Super
Nintendo and Sega Genesis cartridges and
its latest console the retron 5
introduces support for famicom Game Boy
Game Boy Color and Game Boy Advance
games everything is powered by an
embedded Android operating system which
opens the door for valuable features
such as HDMI output savestates and game
genie like cheat codes it's a great
system with loads of promise but it also
has a few issues that need to be ironed
out if hyper Kin wants to please
enthusiasts luckily the retron 5 has an
upgradeable operating system so these
issues may be resolved down the road but
as it is today is hyper Ken's latest
console worth $140 asking price let's
take a look Brett round 5 is a good
looking if unusual console it has 5
cartridge slots 6 controller ports and a
dock in the back for the included
wireless controller like a lot of
aftermarket consoles it's outfitted with
cheap feeling plastic but given its
attractive design its natural to forget
what it's made from and focus on how it
looks
instead the included wireless controller
isn't as good looking or well-made as
the console but as a functional piece of
hardware it's fairly sufficient it
communicates with the retron 5 via
bluetooth and has a battery that lasts
up to 8 hours it would be great if the
battery could recharge passively while
the controller was docked in the back of
the console but in reality you have to
manually connect it to the system using
a rather unusual micro USB to mini-usb
cable thankfully the 10-foot cable
offers plenty of slack so you can play
games while the controller is charging
though it has a few nice features the
controller doesn't quite measure up to
the quality of the original NES Super
Nintendo or Genesis controllers it's
convex buttons are made of hard plastic
and emit an unpleasant hollow clicky
sound instead of implementing a
directional pad Piper can opted to
install an eight-way thumb stick similar
to what you might find on a Neo Geo
Pocket it works well for some games but
it can be a death sentence from playing
difficult games with strict timing and
movement requirements it's also
unfortunate that the system can't be
turned on with the wireless controller
you have to hold down the power button
on the front of the system for five
seconds it's a better controller than
those hyper kins shipped with past
retron systems but not by much
on either side of the system are three
ports one each for NES SNES and Genesis
controllers the retirada 5 will let you
use any controller that's plugged into
the system regardless of the type of
game you're playing so you don't need to
unplug your Genesis controller when you
want to play an nes game the controls
for different systems remap
automatically to other controllers but
you can also remap button layouts
manually within the retron 5sos
unfortunately Game Boy Game Boy Color
and Game Boy Advance games remain
single-player experiences traditionally
you'd have to link to Game Boys together
by a link cable and the retron isn't
currently capable of emulating that
arrangement thankfully it does simulate
multi taps so for player games for every
other console are easily arranged
regardless of the mix of controllers
you've connected to the system
a quick look at the back of the retron
reveals an SD card slot that's used for
cheat codes screenshots firmware updates
and save state files there's also a mini
USB port for recharging controllers an
HDMI port in the AC adapter port hi
broken has thoughtfully included outlet
adapters for Europe United Kingdom
Australia and China most aftermarket
retro consoles use problematic emulation
methods to do the heavy lifting which
doesn't always work with games that use
special chips and circuitry the retron 5
is no more pure in the sense that it
still uses emulation to get the job done
though hyper can confidently asserts at
the retron 5 will ultimately support
every officially licensed game for the
consoles it supports we found a few
exceptions during our tests including
some games that work perfectly on
previous retron consoles this includes
Street Fighter Alpha 2 in the Super
Nintendo and the combination of Sonic
the Hedgehog 2 or 3 with Sonic and
Knuckles for the Sega Genesis unlicensed
games such as pure solar on the Sega
Genesis also failed to make it past the
intro screen again these may just be
temporary issues that a hyper kin can
fix with a future firmware update
unfortunately though the retron supports
multiple systems for the moment it won't
operate if you put in more than one
cartridge at a time with a retron 3 for
example you could keep a card in every
slot and manually select which one you
wanted to play so considering that this
is an unfortunate oversight for the
retron 5 but hyper ken has said that
it's working on an OS setting that would
allow you to do the same thing but for
the moment the system will report an
error if you insert more than one game
if you're used to playing classic games
through composite cables you'll be
impressed by how crisp and colorful
games look with the retron 5 and an HDTV
and because it uses HDMI you don't have
to worry about pal and NTSC video format
incompatibility
those
people will appreciate the sharp hi-def
pixels coming out of the restaurant you
do have the option of smoothing them out
with a few distinct image filters now
one filter works well for every game but
it's a great option to have and you may
find that some games look surprisingly
fresh when the right filter is applied
built-in cheat codes are another
valuable feature in hyper kins
constructing a large database of codes
that it will distribute on its website
but you'll need to supply your own SD
card in order to use them our tests with
an early version of this database were
mostly positive but there's still room
for improvement in the cheat section of
the UI currently there's no way to
automatically sort codes or to activate
and deactivate codes on mass so it can
be a bit of a chore when you want to
find one code out of a list of a few
dozen unfortunately there's no way to
enter new codes by the OS either and
there's no easy way to edit the cheat
database on a PC without manipulating
massive and unintuitive XML files
threats round 5 emulates games after
dumping them to local memory which
includes any saves that are present on
the cartridge as such any new in game
saves you created are also saved locally
but you can also upload them back to the
original cartridge this worked in almost
every case with the exception of Super
Mario RPG but we also had an issue with
the copy of The Legend of Zelda a Link
to the Past in this case the retron
looked as though it was rewriting save
files to the cartridge but it would
consistently fail to rewrite one save in
particular which went mysteriously blank
this resulted in an empty slot in a save
file that remains in limbo on the retron
5 given that you're working with
decades-old games with equally old
batteries there's always the inherent
risk that this feature will be
unreliable but this is never explicitly
spelled out in the OS itself apart from
playing thousands of games perhaps the
most useful feature of the retron 5 is
its ability to use safe States these
allow you to save at any point during
the game and restart right where you
left off it's a convenient feature that
makes getting through some of the more
difficult games a bit easier and given
that a lot of old cartridges have dead
batteries inside safe States can breathe
new life into a cartridge that's no
longer able to store its own saved games
save States cheats and battery backups
are tied to specific games which are
identified by cross-referencing the data
on a cartridge against a database of
known games in the retros local memory
which is supposed to account for the
entire library across all platforms
unfortunately when a game can't be
identified you lose access to cheats and
potentially save States - oddly the
retron 5 couldn't properly identify our
copy of Super Metroid for the Super
Nintendo even though it's a well known
game this might be due to a poor
connection between the cartridge and the
retron but
no alternate method for accessing cheats
and savestates when this occurs taking
all these features and issues into
account it's clear that the retron 5 is
not for everyone on the one hand it does
things with real cartridges that could
only previously be accomplished with PC
based emulators and roms unfortunately
the promise of a great system is
hampered by minor incompatibility issues
and half-baked features the dependence
on cart verification is too strict and
the fact that you can only have one
cartridge in at a time is disappointing
speaking as an avid collector and retro
gaming enthusiast I'm impressed with the
latest retron but given its current
limitations it's not yet a full-time
replacement for my original consoles
still it breathes new life into classic
games and despite its current issues
there are enough arguments to justify
adding it to your repertoire of classic
gaming hardware it's currently the most
expensive console of its type
but if hybrid can fix is the issues with
the OS $140.00 will be a small price to
pay for the new gold standard in retro
gaming consoles